I'll tell you the most impactful guest
spot that turned into probably one of
the biggest opportunities of my life was
was lost my wife was a huge fan of the
show I'd watch the pilot and I was like
cool but I lost the thread so I stopped
watching so I remember she said look and
she was acting at the time she goes if
either one of us gets a job on that show
we're all going to Hawaii if it's a
guest spot we're all going that's the
rule sure enough I got the I got an
audition this is uh the beginning of
season three and I'm like oh man and we
had to go to a kids orientation for uh
for a preschool for our oldest son and
we're like I I got to do this this
audition it's 13 pages of material like
I'll never know this by tomorrow
it's not going to happen and my wife's
like just don't say no anyway long story
short I looked at the material I
wouldn't have it memorized no it wasn't
it was enough book and then I woke up in
the morning saying there's no way I'm
going in on this thing and blowing my
shot and lost and then I read it and I
was like you know what the hell with it
I'm gonna go and I bailed on my kids uh
education